merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à la ministre de la
transition énergétique en l'espace d'une
année la problématique des coûts de
l'énergie vous le savez est devenu
crucial pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens nous entreprises et même nos
collectivités locales dans ce contexte
le Mans à légiférer c'est son rôle et la
loi du 16 août 2022 prévoit que le prix
de l'accès régulier à l'énergie
nucléaire historique la reine ne peut
être inférieure à 49,50 € du
mégawattheure désormais puis
curieusement le gouvernement a introduit
l'obligation de soumettre cette
disposition à l'avis de la Commission
européenne ce que le Conseil d'État dans
son délibéré du 3 février dernier à
formellement identifié comme
inutile puisque ce prix de 49,50 € et
largement inférieur au prix du marché
et non seulement le gouvernement semble
être sourd à cette objection du Conseil
d'État mais vous n'avez à ce jour même
pas solliciter la Commission européenne
monsieur ou madame la ministre je ne
sais pas qui me répondra pouvez-vous
donner les raisons de cette surdité
gouvernementale matinée d'une procrastée
procrastination bien étonnante
alors pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre des
petites des voyages entreprises du
commerce et de l'artisanat
monsieur le sénateur pied-noir j'ai
l'honneur d'essayer de vous répondre ma
collègue la ministre Agnès est en ce
moment même à l'Assemblée nationale sur
le projet de loi nucléaire et s'excuse
de son absence et pourquoi je vais
essayer de répondre à votre question
pertinente et technique avec les
éléments dont je dispose et je ne doute
pas qu'elle y apportera d'autres
éléments à la suite dans cette fin de
journée je vais quand même rappeler
indépendamment des procédures que vous
mentionnez de la saisine et des
réactions du Conseil d'État la
mobilisation du gouvernement français
à l'endroit de notre mix énergétique et
nos travaux en cours avec la Commission
européenne pour faire avancer aussi la
réforme du marché de de l'énergie vous
rappelez quand même à quel point nous
nous continuons à investir massivement
dans le nucléaire 4 à 5 milliards
d'euros par an au niveau 2df 50
milliards d'euros depuis 2015 pour le
grand carénage 6 EPR 2 pour 50 milliards
d'euros et à l'international vous le
savez avec le incl
[Musique]
l'électricité soit vendue à un prix
proche des coûts de production nationale
l'éligibilité du nucléaire assez
contrats l'éligibilité des installations
existantes comme c'est le cas pour la
plupart des centrales en France c'est
une nouvelle encourageante une bonne
base de travail à cette heure et notre
objectif et qu'elle soit adoptée cette
année je vous remercie monsieur piennois
[Applaudissements]
je sais l'implication du gouvernement
même si elle est récente en faveur de la
relance de la filière nucléaire de notre
pays mais cela passe par des moyens à
consolider pour notre outil industriel
qui doit accomplir cette ce programme
nucléaire à savoir EDF qui doit faire
face à une dette colossale de 64
milliards d'euros qui doit faire face à
un mur d'investissement dans les années
à venir et cela l'ucrémont déclarait
lui-même que ce ne sera pas possible si
le prix de la reine reste fixé à 42
euros du mégawater Agnès reconnaissait
elle-même que le prix de production par
EDF était aux alentours de 58 euros donc
on va bien qu'il y a un delta qui qui
est important et je demande au
gouvernement un minimum de cohérence
vous savez qu'il est encore temps de
prendre les mesures nécessaires d'une
part pour ne plus bafouer les décisions
du Parlement de piétiner ses décisions
vous avez actuellement je vous le
rappelle un véhicule législatif à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vous permet de
les faire de le faire je vous invite à
vous en saisir merci merci
[Applaudissements]